[Música]
a publicis apontando pra vocês uma
história que fez muita diferença na
minha vida é uma história muito breve
narrada pelo próprio freud freud
fundador da psicanálise e uma história
que acontece entre o frei de um poeta e
uma flor
ele estava caminhando num dia de verão
lindo na europa é conversando sobre as
coisas da vida quando é o poeta
entristece subitamente se vira para o
freud diz puxa doutor freud que pena eu
tô tão admirado dessa natureza essa
jardim lindo e me deixa tão alegre mais
de uma hora pra outra fiquei muito
triste por imaginar que apesar de toda
essa beleza um dia muito em breve isso
aqui vai acabar essa beleza não vai
durar
apesar de tudo o que a gente sente é de
alegria no momento em que a gente é
fáceis ea natureza ela não dura pra
sempre
e aí o fred é ficar um tempo em silêncio
e depois retoma um pouco a conversa diz
assim pra ele olha mas é aí que você se
engana
não é que apesar da beleza
a flor não dura é que a flor só é bonita
porque não dura é porque ela é
transitório é porque ela é passageira
que a gente consegue extrair daí alguma
beleza
bom eu disse que se essa história
modificou a minha vida na verdade é a
partir dessa história eu tive muita
certeza da escolha que eu fiz é por
trabalhar com alguma coisa que fosse
extremamente humana por alguma coisa que
levasse em conta algo de humano porque o
humano
é isso é isso que se perde se a gente
puder é fazer uma breve lembrança aqui
do campo da biologia a gente vai ver que
na natureza né as coisas é nada se perde
nada se cria tudo se transforma na
natureza humana não natureza humana a
uma perda agente necessariamente sofre
por essa perda e isso é o que nos
constitui como humanos é o que mais nos
constitui propriamente como humanos e é
uma coisa que a gente não pode se
esquecer é e tem a ver com esse texto
lindo sobre a transitoriedade e seu
título da história do freud a gente não
pode se esquecer de que é esse espaço de
perda é exatamente a falta que nos move
não existiria desejo humano não
existiria movimento se não fosse a falta
imaginem um jogo como esse do resto um é
em que ele estivesse completo né é cheio
é não haveria movimento o jogo sequer
começaria então é importante que haja um
espaço vazio para que a gente se
movimente para que a gente se dirija a
alguma coisa que nos falta
e isso é efetivamente aquilo que nos
caracteriza mais propriamente e que nos
difere do pássaro ou da flor o do macaco
o fato de que há essa diz de a esse
desencontro entre aquilo que a gente
deseja e aquilo que a gente tem
existe sempre alguma coisa que fica
faltando é para o ser humano bem porque
será que apesar disso vivemos num
cotidiano e líquido onde nada
pode-se líquida né nesse sentido da
gente não suportar a perda da gente não
suportar os intervalos os espaços vazios
hoje vivemos neste momento especialmente
nas últimas duas décadas com todos os
adventos é da ciência com todos os
adventos da tecnologia
vivemos massacrados por uma continuidade
temporal por uma é permanência é de
ligação de estarmos o tempo todo
antenados onde a gente tem é a sensação
de que esse tempo é contínuo é sem pausa
é sem perda é sem falta
e é como se a gente tivesse se dirigindo
cada vez mais a esse tipo de situação
sem se perguntar minimamente para onde
vamos com tudo isso é de que forma que a
gente vai viver os próximos anos a
partir disso bem vivemos a cimpor como
se fosse numa festa numa festa contínua
é hoje em dia é muito é impressionante
como é pelo fato da gente não se
desligar das redes sociais
a obrigação que as redes sociais nos
colocam é de que a gente esteja o tempo
todo lindo alegre feliz mostrando né as
nossas melhores caras dos nossos
melhores programas as nossas é mais
bonitas posições m interruptamente é uma
festa sem festa de uma forma inclusive
que tenha que ter a participação do
outro ali o tempo todo pra me confirmar
nessa festa ininterrupta
nesse gozo que é sem expansão sem
intervalo é esse outro que me confirma
nesse nesse lugar de uma festa absoluta
de uma felicidade sem intervalo
é é um outro que entra na minha
intimidade fazendo uma espécie de a
falta de descanso
são falta de diferença entre o que é
público eo que é privado né
hoje é como se a gente tivesse que é
fazer na vida pública aquilo que a gente
faz na privada para brincar um pouco é
sem nenhuma é pausa para se perguntar
sobre as conseqüências disso para onde
isso tudo nos leva a final é eu vou eu
como eu já disse é um cotidiano líquido
e é um cotidiano de excessos eu vou
trazer então alguns exemplos né mais
palatáveis para tornar mais próximo isso
que eu tenho certeza que é parte da vida
cotidiana de todos nós é a primeira é
assim a primeira situação muito evidente
de excessos que a gente vive no nosso
cotidiano é o excesso de objetos então é
outro dia mesmo né eu participei dessa
cena uma criança de 5 anos chegava de
uma festa infantil lotada de brindes em
túlio os brindes é anexou aos outros
1574 brindes que ele já tinha dentro do
armário toda vez que ele abre o armário
os brindes caem em cima da cabeça dele e
sem que essa criança de 5 anos consiga
ter tempo para brincar com isso tudo que
ele vai guardando com isso tudo que ele
vai acumulando somos uma geração de
acumuladores né
e obviamente essa criança não tem tempo
para brincar porque do lado de cá seus
pais também estão muito mais preocupados
incite ao tempo dessa criança de modo a
que ele cumpra suas deficiências que ele
seja é enfim com cinco anos de idade um
profissional perfeito
então é isso o excesso de objetos
por outro lado um excesso de notícias
é incrível pensar que em 1921 jornal
tinha 50 vezes
- palavras do que em 2017 50 vezes menos
palavras e se a gente não considerar uav
as versões online do jornal
aí a gente multiplica por 500 esse
número é muita informação sem que a
gente tenha a menor capacidade de digeri
las
a gente não tem tempo para digerir a
quantidade de informações que a gente
recebe diariamente então um excesso aí
de informações também e o terceiro é o
excesso que eu trago é para a gente
refletir um pouco é o excesso de
mensagens é eu me lembrava que é até
muito pouco tempo atrás eu diria três
décadas a forma de comunicação entre
duas pessoas distantes era a carta era
mais efetiva e era mais presente na
cultura até muito pouco tempo atrás a
carta é aquilo uma forma de comunicação
arcaica é esquecida e que inclui um
intervalo de tempo um intervalo um
espaço mínimo entre o destinatário para
onde essa carta vai e o remetente de
onde essa carta sai esse espaço foi
limado da cultura em 20 anos
a gente primeiro teve ali ainda alguma é
é inserção dos emails na nossa vida mas
hoje uma adolescente de 17 anos não sabe
o que é um e mail
já ouviu falar mas diz que não recebe
não responde por e mail ou seja é o
tempo todo uma mensagem que chega
instantaneamente de forma que a gente
também só se confirme diante do outro
quando a gente percebe por exemplo ele
pelo aplicativo que o outro leu a nossa
mensagem
a gente não acredita mais nesse pequeno
espaço que pode haver
entre a gente e o outro é sempre com
muita aflição que isso tudo vai se dando
e aí é não teria problema nenhum
se isso tudo tivesse acontecendo ea
gente observasse que estamos todos mais
felizes efetivamente estamos todos menos
angustiados mas não é isso que a gente
percebe se por um lado não é possível
ficar fazendo um saudosismo disso é e
reclamar e condenar os avanços
tecnológicos tão radicais que inseriram
tanta diferença no nosso comportamento
se não é possível é ter saudade disso
por outro lado é inevitável que a gente
pare pause minimamente pra pensar pra
ficar com essas questões porque uma
festa e nem interrupta é a mesma coisa
que uma angústia
a verdade é que a gente sente essa
ausência de contraste
da mesma forma então se eu tô 200 horas
por dia feliz
é mais ou menos a mesma coisa de eu
estar 200 horas por dia o chiado no
seguinte sentido é eu não tenho como
comparar nem eu não tenho uma tristeza
que me diga de uma alegria e vice versa
é tudo um certo amortecimento eu vou dar
um dado é estatístico pra vocês é uma
pesquisa que saiu essa semana americana
é é alarmante hoje 20 por cento de toda
a população adulta americana faz uso de
algum medicamento psiquiátrico 10% de
toda criança em idade escolar em escola
faz uso de algum medicamento ou
psiquiátrico e 25% dos jovens
universitários americanos estão nessa
mesma
a tática não são números que dizem um
pouco de que esses avanços
essa forma radical com que o mundo é
acabou se transformando nas últimas
décadas de modo a não considerar a pausa
o intervalo na a separação a distância
que há entre uma coisa e outra isso tem
como efeito a angústia
bem eu vou trazer três paradoxos disso
tudo que estão aí presentes na nossa
vida
a primeira das curiosidades é o fato da
gente perceber que hoje para alguma
coisa se real ela primeiro tem que ser
virtual
então é jovens que começam e terminam o
seu relacionamento é pela internet antes
mesmo de se beijarem né eles combinam
isso
depois é eles se beijam por exemplo é a
maneira como a gente está num evento e
se a gente não postar na rede social
esse evento ele não terá existido é essa
sensação moderna né então a maneira como
esse virtual ele passou a ser anterior
ao real colocando consequências no real
isso não é sem consequências porque a
gente entende e sempre entendeu como
real é o segundo paradoxo é que quando
vão mais informações e palavras a gente
é com com mais palavras a gente é é
popular digamos assim o nosso dia
não necessariamente isso se reverte com
uma certa é firmeza nos nossos
compromissos
a gente fala muito e faz pouco eu eu vou
trazer um exemplo aqui quando eu era é
pequena e fazia balé
minha mãe dizia assim pra mim olha três
horas da tarde esteja na porta do balé
estarei buscando
bom se chegasse 3 e 10 ou 13 15 e eu não
estivesse na porta eu tinha morrido ou
eu iria morrer porque ela ia me matar se
eu não sobreviveria essa experiência de
toda forma então os compromissos com a
agilidade das mensagens e das
informações que eles vão ficando mais
esgarçadas e numa numa visão mais ampla
é isso que a gente compartilha a gente
não compartilha outra coisa nós estamos
aqui no campo simbólico que é esse
espaço onde a gente compartilha palavras
e essas palavras estão se tornando mais
gastas e elas estão se tornando mais é
minha - levadas a sério e o terceiro
paradoxo é o fato de que a gente
certamente economiza muito tempo com a
modernidade mas esse tempo não se
reverte em tempo real que a gente possa
utilizar pra esse ócio produtivo é pra
esse espaço que a gente poderia ter a um
ótimo exemplo é quando a gente era até
também muito pouco tempo atrás não
existia o banco online é a gente ficava
40 minutos na fila do banco que a gente
faz com esses 40 minutos hoje onde é que
estão os 40 minutos da semana que a
gente gastava na fila do banco
a gente não sabe isso se subverteu em
outra coisa né passou a ser uma
exigência de mais um ou dois ou três
compromissos é então a esse paradoxo é
com relação ao tempo bom e bom isso gera
uma hiperatividade somos todos e
operativos vivemos numa cultura que
incentiva a hiperatividade é tem um
pouco de preconceito com a passividade é
e aí a gente se esquece que é só nesse
tempo nessa pausa e nesse intervalo
falou que a gente poderia ser
surpreendido por alguma novidade por
alguma coisa da ordem da criação o
desejo depende disso pra ir pra aparecer
para existir e pra e para se tornar é
efetivo na nossa vida é voltando a flor
do freud é importante que uma safra
termine aqui outra possa de vir e que a
gente reconheça que é no término de uma
safra que uma outra pode vir
é a gente está cada vez mais refratário
e tudo isso é como se a gente pudesse
ignorar isso que é o principal do humano
né que é somos todos passageiros - o
trocador e motorista
bom eu vou é ler pra vocês uma frase que
eu acho lapidar da clarice lispector
exatamente pra finalizar e sobre sobre
esse tema de hoje minha alegria também
vem da minha mais profunda tristeza ea
tristeza é uma alegria falhada
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]